what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel okay so we are back with
Injustice year one and we're actually
going to split volume two or I guess you
know volume two into two parts and even
it'll make sense we're actually going to
make two videos out of the second half
of Injustice and the reason why is
because there's a lot of stuff to cover
here but there's also a lot of things I
just want to talk about a lot of things
that I really really want to I really
want to discuss because as you guys know
I love getting like super deep into this
because it's cool to see what writers do
with stories and the outcomes that we
get whether it's the intention of the
writer or not whether it's something
that I just perceive a certain way and
it just creates a cruel discussion
whatever the reason is I love bringing
those things in here now of course uh in
the last video you guys you guys freaked
you guys freaked at the end of the last
video because it was like yeah man Dick
Grayson died catch you all later peace
and people were just like no no you
can't just leave us there you got to
keep going and so we're we're we're
we're keeping on keeping on but with the
death of Dick Grayson it was a huge deal
and it's not like it was because the
death of Superman I mean The Death of
Superman would have been big but it was
nowhere near as impactful as the death
of Dick Grayson and the reason why is
because it was really kind of isolated
to the superhero Community but
superheroes and even some super villains
look to Dick Grayson and said that's a
man we aspire to be not because he has
powers Dick Grayson has no powers dick
Grayson's just extremely acrobatic he's
got all kinds of martial arts skills
he's a really good detective almost
everything he learned he had from the
training of Batman and a handful of
other people people looked to Dick
Grayson as the best of them because of
what he stood for because he was like
this Incorruptible Shining Light in a
world of superheroes whose moral code
was getting ever darker it was like he
was the one infallible thing the one guy
who didn't shift he was the bright light
he was the spark you know he was the the
smile and the crowd of frowning people
and because of that people loved him the
superhero Community loved him fans of
Nightwing loved him and so to see his
character die like that was just
crushing not only that the way it
happened was so unique we expect that
when superheroes die it's this grandiose
thing you know Superman fighting
doomsday and they're just beating each
other to death you know and then it's
just this punch at the same time and
windows shatter buildings fall the world
stands still like we expect just these
grandiose situations Dick Grayson was
hit in the head with a baton fell down
and broke his neck on a rock and that
was it it was Tom Taylor saying here's
how fast Heroes can fall and here's how
fast everything can turn now with
regards to Catwoman's character you know
picking up with her in this section of
Injustice the way that she written is
incredible I mean it's it's it's really
really good here because Tom Taylor
really plays it fast and loose with how
she stands as really kind of like an
anti-hero really a villain kind of on
again off again villain the cool thing
about Catwoman is you could label her as
a villain but then you could label her
as a hero depending on how it is that
you look at her that's why I say Tom
Taylor kind of bounces back and forth
with regards to her being a villain
she's breaking into a man's home with
regards to her being a hero she's
breaking into the home of a man who
cheated people out of their homes and so
it creates this really interesting
dichotomy because if I took you to the
side of a lake and I said a guy named
Jim is getting ready to kill a guy named
Steve and take his fish then if you
witness that action take place if you
saw Jim come along stab Steve to death
and take his fish on the surface you
would be like well that's a terrible
thing to do that's an awful thing to do
now Jim and Steve have never met they
don't know each other but what if I were
to make the waters a little murkier and
I were to say well Jim didn't kill Steve
just for the purpose of murder Jim
killed Steve because Jim has a family to
feed and he did what we what he thought
was necessary to feed his family for
some people they may say well he's still
a murderer and he still deserves to be
punished for his crimes other may say
well I mean he is doing the best he can
he's trying to feed his family you know
intention versus impact it changes
everything it changes the entire
argument and so that's why on one hand
Selena Kyle's a criminal on the other
hand she's a hero it depends on what
side of the aisle you're looking at her
from for the families that were cheated
out of their you know cheated out of
their homes by this guy Selena Kyle's a
great charact a great person she's
helping them get what they feel they
deserve for that guy she's a bad person
now of course in the middle of all this
Superman makes his appearance but
Superman doesn't show up here because
he's just like parking a last Selena
Kyle's breaking into someone's home and
I should go go stop her he shows up here
because he's got a much bigger picture
now of course with Catwoman being how
she is spending so much time with Batman
she knows what's going on with Superman
or at least to the degree that he's kind
of trying to impose this new world order
but more so than that when it comes to
fighting Superman that she knows how to
deal with him you know and she even goes
as far as to say that you know when she
jumps out the window tries to escape
Superman grabs her and brings her to the
ground she says she has two earrings one
this emerald and one this Kryptonite and
of course the green Kryptonite will give
her a momentary chance to escape but
once she takes off down into the sewers
of course Superman uses his heat vision
and destroys her earring but at this
point he says here's why I'm here I
don't care that you're breaking into the
home of a man that stole from you know
the cheated people out of their homes
I've got bigger fish to fry what he says
is you need to go talk to Bruce Wayne
and she says why and he says because
Nightwing's dead now Catwoman's reaction
to this situation tells us everything
the Catwoman's always been in a lot of
ways on the outside looking in when it
came to the Batman Mythos but on the
occasional time that she was on the
inside she was inside long enough to
know the relationship between Bruce
Wayne and night Wayne you know she was
on the inside long enough to know how
the two of them related to one another
they were very much Father and Son for
Bruce Wayne to lose Dick Grayson is a
crushing experience her initial response
is you're his best friend you're his
best friend go talk to him go talk to
your friend and help him deal help him
get over this Superman of course takes
the frat boy approach well no too much
has happened there's way too much going
on the two of us can't really deal with
this now we know that's nonsense and
that's the first thing toen Kyle says
you're a coward you're a coward and
you're full of crap you're you are full
of hooa juice that is not the case at
all she knows that when it comes down to
a two friends with a friendship as
strong as Batman and Superman will work
it out if he really took this
opportunity to kind of turn it around to
go to Batman and say look I'm sorry for
everything that I've done I've literally
just been been a man grieving the two of
them could have sat down and they could
have grieved over the people they cared
about together that's what Tom Taylor's
getting at here Tom Taylor's like you
know Superman lost Lis Lane Batman lost
Dick Grayson sure the reason why Batman
lock lost di Grayson was due to the
actions of Superman and creating this
Rift in the superhero Community but the
fact remains they've both lost people
that are close to them and Catwoman's
like mourn your loss together go be
friends go cry on each other's shoulders
but in the end Superman just says no and
so Catwoman says okay fine then I will
go talk to him but you need to
understand it's very easy to look at the
other side it's very easy to be a man in
a home whose children are hungry and
then feed someone across the street
because you feel like you're doing the
right thing but she says you don't do
that when you're a parent and your kids
are hungry you feed your kids first and
then you worry about the neighbors
across the street and that's what she
says you know you can look at the world
you can say man the world needs saving
sure the world needs saving and that's a
very good sentiment but before you save
the world save your home save the people
here in the United States save people
who are being cheated out of the things
that they have by corporate you know
individuals by people who are just
gaming the system and so with this
little message that she gives to
Superman she basically takes off you
know to go see Bruce Wayne and this is
why I say this is so beautiful because
when she gets in there the first person
she comes across is Alfred who's just
not really a drunken stuper so much as
just kind of drowning as sorrows and
alcohol and we never see Alfred like
this we never see Alfred this crushed
broken down falling apart it's always
like Alfred's like the one guy that's
got it together right like Alfred's like
yeah man you know I'm the one guy that's
holding it together Bruce Wayne lost his
parents he went crazy decided to dress
as a bat and beat up people in the
middle of the night but I am Alfred I've
got my [__] together I can hold it I can
I can keep myself sane to see him like
this is like damn not only that we
basically pick up with Bruce Wayne and
of course you know when when Catwoman
gets down there she's like dude Bruce
stop you have to stop punish in yourself
you have to calm down even if it's only
for today don't be Batman be Bruce Wayne
be human I will be here to pick up the
pieces and it's so awesome because now
it's this is not Batman and Catwoman
this is Bruce Wayne and Selena Kyle and
you will never see a moment when the two
of these characters are more human than
they are right now now following this we
basically pick up with with Catwoman and
Batman going back and doing their thing
I don't mean going back and like bumping
uglies I'm sure they did but they
basically meet up with the president of
the United States now the reason why
they're meeting up with the president is
because Superman's continuing his
campaign to basically Force peace across
the world and that's the issue here
peace at the end of a gun is U it's a
short-term thing it's never going to
last and the reason why is because it
lasts only so long as the gun is pointed
but as soon as that gun drops down well
then suddenly things are back to the way
they were before and that's what the
President says you know sure Superman
has forced a forced a peace treaty
between the Nations between the leaders
of of Israel and Palestine sure we have
Wonder Woman who appeared in Burma and
basically ceased fighting that's been
going on for decades you know when it
comes to to Syria when it comes to all
these different territories all these
different Waring factions who have been
fighting for whatever reason yes there
is a temporary peace but Bruce Wayne
says that's the problem it's temporary
you know these these feuds aren't over
something small you know it's not like
the king's wife ran off with the guy of
another country these are blood feuds
they go back decades half the people who
were fighting don't even know why
they're fighting they're just fighting
because that's what you do that's just
how they live they were born they were
taught to hate that group over there and
they've been fighting them ever since
they were older enough to walk or carry
a gun and so because of that Batman and
cwom they say look we will help you in
your goal Mr President of trying to deal
with Superman of trying to basically
write this ship get things back to the
way they were before but what they say
is if you want us to help you you need
to help us you need to start fixing your
country stop just abandoning it you know
stop letting your your policies run wild
and benefit corporations make sure that
people here on the home front are taken
care of the way they need to be now of
course ultimately the president's kind
of you know his back's against the wall
he doesn't really have a choice in the
matter and so we essentially pick up
with the idea that the government's kind
of made this list of individuals that
haven't really chosen a side they they
haven't chosen the side of Superman they
haven't chosen the side of Batman
they're just kind of doing their own
thing now of course this is like Black
Lightning this is Black Canary you know
this is Huntress a handful of people
here and there they're really like
smalltime characters in a lot of
different ways but the great thing about
Batman is that he can take a small group
of people that aren't wildly capable
with the exception of Captain Adam that
dude's insane but he can take a a small
group of people and he can whip them
into something formidable and that's
exactly what Batman intends to do he's
essentially forming his own Justice
League it's Batman's Justice Le League
versus Superman's Justice League and
what they do is they essentially go
around to all these different
individuals to these various people here
and kind of rally them together so in
the end you've got you know you got
green arrow you got Black Canary you got
Huntress you got Black Lightning you got
you know Batwoman you got Aquaman
Captain Adam you have all these guys who
are considered you know small time for
whatever reason are were never really
brought in or don't consider themselves
part of the Justice League and in
response to that they're basically
working on behalf of Batman to go
against Superman and so from here we
switch over to the perspective of Billy
Batson now this is one of the cool
things about the stories is that Tom
Taylor peppers in these little things
here and there these little you know
really one shots for lack of a better
word he Peppers these end of the stories
to give us like a better perspective of
everything that's going on and with
regards to Billy Batson as we know you
know he is the other half of Shazam
Billy Batson shouts the word Shazam he
becomes Shazam Captain Marvel whatever
it is that you want to call him but the
fact remains that he becomes one of the
most capable superheroes who's right up
there with Superman and what we find out
is the reason why Billy basson is going
around and interviewing these people and
asking them how they feel about
Superman's stance of imposing peace in
the world is because shortly before that
Shazam alongside the rest of the Justice
League had faced off against Black Adam
and the reason why was because someone
had attacked kak and Black Adam being
you know do very Dr doomes in the sense
that he swears absolute loyalty to his
home country and will defend it and
destroy all opposition that you know
creates any measure of danger to his
people he's drawn the ey of the Justice
League and so in this massive battle in
this conflict Wonder Woman Superman and
Shazam sees Black Adam and this is one
of the craziest things here because
Wonder Woman wraps the lasso of Truth
around him and says tell me your magic
word now of course one of the first
things she also asks is will you ever
stop killing and he says no if anybody
threatens kondak I will kill them not
only that he says your world order this
this dictatorship that you're imposing
will affect my country and so I will
fight you to my dying breath basically
saying if all else fails I will be the
last hold out I will be the one last
person with any measure of superhuman
powers that will face off against you
until the day I die and so the Justice
League looks at him and says well this
guy's a lost cause he's never going to
be on our side and he's wildly
formidable in his abilities he could
Challenge almost each and every one of
us if you were to face off against us
alone and so in in the mind of Wonder
Woman we basically have to eliminate him
now this is a crushing oh my God this is
so crushing because he looks to he looks
to Shazam and he says promise me condu
will be safe now this is huge because
Black Adam and Shazam have been enemies
forever I mean you know Black Adam was
first introduced by otob bender and CC
Becka I think way back in the day when
he was supposed to be like a one-off
villain in the old uh faucet Comics
Publications when DC you know sued
Foster Publications and tied them up in
court for 20 years or however long it
was and then brought Shazam back in the
1970s he got a larger role but he was
always directly intertwined with the
Shazam family and always fought Shazam
and so it's like the mortal enemy of
Shazam telling him please make sure my
people are safe because he knows what's
coming and that's what Wonder Woman does
she says tell us what's your magic word
and he shouts the word Shazam and
reverts back to his old form and that's
the issue here you know with this guy
basically fading away into absolute
nothingness is this notion that no one
knows if he'll survive the experience
not only that Black Adam is basically
gone from the landscape or at the very
least that seems to be the case but the
other half of this is that Billy
Batson's been going through and talking
to all these different people and they
all react differently and that's the
crazy thing about this is some of the
responses are from people who have no
idea what's going on but they pretend
that they do well I'm glad that
Superman's imposing this dictatorship
because he's going after all those
people over there and that's a stance
that a lot of people take you know they
say yeah those folks over there are bad
well okay I mean it's cool to have that
policy but what happens when the
government that views those people as
the enemy starts to view you as the
enemy do you still believe that that's
okay is it still like yeah we should
arbitrarily round people up or does the
does your opin opinion suddenly change
well no it's okay to arbitrarily round
people up as long as I'm not one of the
people they're rounding up at the same
time you have people who are informed on
what's going on who are aware of what's
going on some of whom still agree with
Superman's actions and so it's all
coming you know from these these
different walks of life these different
perspectives you know for example
there's one woman that says I came to
this country to escape an oppressive
rule you know I found peace for a Time
the issue with this is that these these
superheroes aren't looking to rule a
country they're looking to rule the
world if they succeed where do you go
there's no safe Haven there's no place
you can go where you can be safe it's
worldwide domination you know it's like
a planet crashing into Earth yeah sure I
mean it'd be awesome if we could Escape
if it was a meteor crashing into like
the United States you might be able to
find Safe Haven in Europe somewhere or
maybe you know somewhere down in the in
the Antarctic but if it's the planet
being destroyed then where you going to
go and so ultimately Billy Batson
basically sits down with himself he
talks with Shazam and he says do you
think this is okay do you think this is
smart and of course you know Shazam
offers the wisdom of Solomon you know
it's one of his abilities but but Billy
basson says I'm 12 years old I don't
understand that explain it to me in in
kidswords you know and he says what do
you see if you don't have all this
wisdom what do you see and Billy basson
says I see people who feel hopeless I
see a grieving superhero who believes
that the success or the the source of of
his problem was found in villains who
were able to get away with their crimes
I see a man taking all the wrong actions
who would try to save the world and at
the same time lead to its ruin he says
maybe you're right about this maybe what
Superman is doing is okay but maybe what
he's doing is not okay and maybe what
he's doing will lead to the destruction
of everything and so from here we pick
up with uh with metropolis and the
reason why is because you know from what
Tom Taylor tells us is that it's been
about a month since all these events
happen you know the destruction of
metropolis and everything that's taken
place so far but we also find out that
there's a survivor in Metropolis and no
one knows who it is there's just some
guy who's alive down there and of course
this is initially picked up by some guy
with just a radio eventually picked up
by the Justice League but trying to
search through its source seems almost
impossible and so what happens is the
Superman basically says look you know if
there is a person who's alive and
Metropolis we're not ignoring it you
know we have to save this last Prestige
now in truth this isn't really Superman
being a good guy this is Superman hoping
he could have saved at least one person
because that's all this is Superman is
doing all this because he believes that
if he can make the world a better place
that he's going back and saving
everybody in Metropolis he's keeping
that event from happening again you know
saving the world means saving Lois Lane
we know that's not the case but that's
the stance that he's taking and so what
happens is when they get there you know
Superman uses his abilities he looks
through different buildings and
ultimately comes across a giant leg a
safe room for lack of a better word and
once this once it's brought open you
know once they get the entire thing
opened up we find out the Survivor is
Lex Luther now this is where Tom
Taylor's stance on the relationship
between Superman and Lex Luther changes
dramatically we always viewed the the
classic Lex Luther and the classic
Superman as mortal enemies that's not
the case the two of them are friends and
it appears as though they have been for
quite some time not only that we find
out that Lex Luthor had basically hired
a Speedster in an emergency this
Speedster was basically on retainer and
what would happen is that if there was
some kind of a massive emergency in
Metropolis the job of this Speedster
would be to do nothing more than to get
Lex Luther from wherever he was in the
city of metropolis to the safe room and
out of Harm's Way the issue is that the
the speeder who appears looks like it's
Jesse quick uh ultimately didn't make it
that she had gone back out tried to save
people tried to be the hero and in the
in the time that it took basically died
perished in the explosion and so because
of this you know when Lex Luther is
brought back to the uh brought back to
the to the Justice League Watchtower you
know he says look if what you want is a
better world if what you you know
because after the Justice League
basically explains everything you know
he says look if what you guys are trying
to do is create a better world you can't
do it by beating people over the head
with a hammer now I wouldn't say that
Lex Luther is right here you know to
quote Kevin spacy from Seven we don't
live in a world where you can just walk
up to a person and tap them on the
shoulder it doesn't work that way you
have to walk them up walk up to them and
hit them in the head with a sledgehammer
and then you'll notice you have their
full attention and that's what
Superman's been doing he has the world's
attention right now Lex Luther says now
it's time to take the next step you have
the attention of the world all eyes are
on you everybody wants to know what the
next step is because people are
terrified that the next step will be
absolute dictatorship people who
disagree with Superman's views will be
whisked away to you know someplace where
they'll be detained or they'll just be
outright executed on the spot and so
because of that Lex Luther says you have
a chance to mold the world to to create
a world that loves you all you have to
do is trust me and let me help you with
this now of course the Justice League's
response and really Wonder Woman's
response is why in the hell should we
trust you and he says I know every last
one of your identities Diana Prince Hal
Jordan Billy Batson Barry Allen Clark
Kint I know every last one of your
secret identities I've known for a long
time and I've never told a soul if I was
really a person that can't be trusted
why would I have kept that to myself I
would have dumped your identities to the
world and so he says trust me let me
join your Justice League let me be part
of your team and let me help you solve
the problem of how to fix the world now
following this uh Tom Taylor begins the
process of sort of sitting Superman down
this path that he can't come back from I
mean he's been doing that a lot you know
so far in the story but this is really
the point where Superman's like at this
point of no return he's at like the
Event Horizon so to speak of his really
is his career as a superhero initially
what this does is this picks up with hog
girl and hog girl is effectively just
like on a mission I mean it's nothing
insane she's basically just on a random
Mission but in the middle of all this
she's basically attacked by a
combination of Batman's forces Batman
Catwoman Black Lightning Captain Adam
the whole nine yards and in the end
she's basically taken prisoner now what
it is that Batman does with this we'll
find out later on but from here we
jumped Wonder Woman in a place called
Mogadishu now a story involving her
character really in any form of fashion
wouldn't really be a good Wonder Woman
story if it didn't focus on the the
female side of things the the woman's
side of things and Wonder Woman has
always been like the first lady of
comics in a lot of ways I mean she was
always kind of like the predecessor for
all the strong female leads that have
come out in comics and of course with
her being with her character always
having been written the way it is it's
always that she really stands up for
women's rights more so than anything
else but with regards to the territory
of Mogadishu what's been going on here
is she basically says that it's a war
torn territory where it's largely ruled
by men that women are subservient that a
lot of men have their way with these
different women and uh and they're
they're very much helpless in the face
of such oppression and so with Wonder
Woman coming here it's for no other
purpose than to sort of have this Branch
off of you know World Dominion so to
speak when she basically says this goal
is going to be to give these women the
chance to kind of take themselves out of
Oppression and what she does is she
basically strips these men of their guns
and she hands them over to the other
women and she says do what you will take
your revenge and in response they
execute every last one of the men that
are in this camp now now from here we
jump back to the Watchtower and the
question that the Justice League have
that Superman has is where have you been
your communicator's been deactivated
this is again Wonder Woman going rogue
and we've talked about this before we
talked about this in the last video that
Wonder Woman usually always does that
when it's stories like kingdom come or
something like that Wonder Woman's
always depicted as being a lot more
manipulative and much darker than she
normally is and even in the main DC line
of comics it can be that way and the
reason why is because Wonder Woman is a
warrior she's a warrior princess and so
for her she looks at her position as I
am a person of War I am goddess of war
you know so to speak depending on what
story that you're looking at and because
of that she's basically looking to
ensure that this world Dominion when it
comes to light when it actually takes
place that those individuals who deserve
their freedom get their freedom and that
no one's left behind in addition to this
when the question is asked where's hot
girl what's happened to her uh Lex
Luther's initial response is well is
Batman I mean it's always Batman you
know Batman took her we just don't know
where now at this point something to
keep in mind is that this is all just a
guessing game no one knows for sure
where it is that hot girl's at all they
know is that she's just gone now of
course Catwoman also as asked the
question here she's like look this is
going to draw the attention of the
Justice League they're going to realize
that she's gone and Batman simply
responds by saying no they're not going
to know that hot girl is gone and the
reason why is because they're not going
to be looking for her and they're not
going to be looking for her because
she's going to go back to the Justice
League Watchtower now in terms of who
this person is that's caught girl I want
to say but I'm not going to I'm not
going to reveal that yet it's actually a
really really really cool reveal but
from here we pick up with the Justice
League having this great discussion on
the idea of what they're roles are and
how Batman impacts them and that's the
coolest thing is because Batman's
greatest weapon isn't really fear or
anything like that it's seeding doubt
it's the confidence that he has and the
fear among the Justice League that
Batman will have a way to defeat them
now this concern is not without Merit I
mean we've seen a lot of different
stories especially Tower of Babel where
Batman has a contingency plan for
everything that was the whole basis of
the Tower of Babel story what happens if
someone gets a hold of the plans that
Batman has on how to incapacitate the
Justice League and uses them against the
Justice League then what happens next
you know we've seen a lot of those
things but keep in mind here Damen Wayne
had still defected away from Batman and
he's still on the side of the Justice
League and so where the Justice League
themselves begin to argue where they
begin to bicker where there's a lot of
infighting in terms of whether or not
hot girl can be trusted after having
vanished and then suddenly reappearing
Daman says this is Batman's plan this is
Batman's goal this is what he does he
seeds doubt he reaps conflict he
destabilizes you and then he comes in
and conquers you when you're at your
weakest and so what Damen says is do not
do that in addition Lex Luther comes to
daman's Aid and says that makes the most
sense if you're Batman and you don't
have the physical abilities to take out
Superman Wonder Woman Shazam the Green
Lantern then you take them out through
other means you wage a psychological war
against them you get them to fight each
other and then you turn around and you
bring them down now while all this is
happening we basically have the planet
apocalypse we have dark side moving
towards the Conquering of Earth and the
reason for this is because of the fact
that through his weaknesses through his
observations you know by virtue of his
son calac as well as you know Dark Side
himself the indication seems to be here
that Earth is ripe for the picking that
of all the times that dark sides tried
to conquer Earth and always failed that
now is the time to do it because the
superhero Community is fractured lowest
Lane's dead Superman's grieving what
dark side doesn't realize here is that
Superman is in a place where he's at his
most dangerous you know a fox is never
more dangerous than when it's cornered
and so because of that uh Dark Side
basically begins to make preparations
for an invasion of Earth at the same
time Lex Luther says look Superman your
War to basically wage dominion over the
planet Earth is just as much a political
war as it is of physical war and so he
says it's not enough to Simply impose
peace you have to win the hearts and
minds of the people now Lex Luther is
playing a dangerous game here and the
reason why is because he has an ulterior
motive and we'll find out what that is
but in the midst of Superman basically
speaking out to the world and saying hey
look you know here's where I'm coming
from here's why I'm acting the way I am
here's why I'm doing the things that
I've done it's because I've lost
something significant I've lost the most
important thing that a person can lose
I've lost my family and I didn't want
other people to suffer the same fate if
I had the power to stop it he's very
much acting in accordance to what Batman
does the issue here is that Superman is
taking the next step where Batman always
refused to do that and that's the cool
thing about all this is Tom Taylor
saying like this is the next step for
Batman Batman is one broken neck away
from being Superman right now in this
position right here but Batman always
had more self-control Batman always
realized this is where that road would
take him and so because of that Superman
in the midst of his of his huge speech
is basically met or besieged upon by all
these different pair of demons now of
course again this is this it's kind of
cool to see calac showing up here it's
kind of cool to see you know the the
forces of Apocalypse invading the Earth
but it's not Tom Taylor doing this just
for the sake of doing it it's not Tom
Taylor saying hey guys wouldn't it be
cool if like a dark side invaded the
Earth in like the middle of Injustice it
is cool it's it's really cool but
there's a much bigger goal that Tom
Taylor's looking for here the goal
itself is not immediately known instead
we basically have Superman facing off
against calac and absolutely pummeling
him as well as these boom tubes opening
up from different locations across the
world now this is something that I also
wanted to explain because I don't know
if I'd ever ran over this before but for
those of you guys who are always curious
about the the concept of like Apocalypse
of the new Gods things like that when it
comes to DC Comics you have a Multiverse
you have 52 different universes but
there's only one apocalypse there's only
one new genesis there's only one dark
side only one high father you can only
access apocalypse through boom tubes
created by mother boxes you can't fly
outside the Multiverse and go to the
planet Apocalypse at least not that I'm
aware of instead it can only be accessed
by way of Boom tubes but with these
tubes opening up across the world it's
just this full scale Invasion hitting
the most populated areas killing as many
people as possible in demoralizing
what's left of the superhero Community
the problem with this is that this
Gambit on behalf of dark side with calac
telling Superman you know no you're the
same Superman we've always known you
won't kill anybody you never kill
anybody and that's why we always win
because we're willing to do whatever it
takes in order to achieve our goal and
you're not willing to that's why we're
launching this Invasion now and that's
why we're going to be successful with
this Gambit it's bad it's it doesn't pay
off and the reason why is because
Superman basically says you're right
normally I would have just rolled over I
never would have killed you but things
are different now and you're going to
die and he he goes through and he he
basically obliterates calac along with a
handful of these parad demons not only
that in the middle of these rescue
efforts he races over to the flash he
races over to Barry Allen and that's the
coolest thing about this is this entire
conversation when he shows up to Barry
Allen and says we need to talk this
takes place in the length of a breath I
mean it takes place it's almost as cool
as the chess match between Superman and
the Flash and we'll talk about that here
uh I probably in the next video but he
basically says look calac essentially
told me look I care more about the lives
of my enemies than the lives of my
people is that true do you really think
that's true do you really think I'm a
person that comes off that way do we
really need to take the next step is it
necessary for us to begin considering
killing people now of course Barry Allen
says no that's ridiculous but Suman says
you're the fastest man alive you can
think faster than almost anybody here do
you see an alternative to this and in
the end Barry Allan says no sometimes
you come across an enemy where the only
way to defeat them is to kill them
because they will just keep coming and
coming and coming they'll just keep
coming back time and time again and so
sometimes the only way to keep them from
coming back is to take away their
ability to come back it's like crowds
that right the easiest way to silence a
noisy crowd is not to be noisier than
they are is to take away their ability
to make noise then you'll find their
absolutely silent that's basically the
case is being made here and so in
response Superman travels to the sun
absorbs a massive amount of solar
radiation comes back to Earth and
destroys every single pair of demon
kills every last one of them now where
the world celebrates where the world
looks at this and and cheers the name of
Superman Batman looks on and says no
says oh my God no because this is now
Superman taking the next step prior to
this Superman was just beating people up
prior to this he was just punishing
superheroes or punishing super villains
you know with the utmost Force now he's
become a killer now Superman is a
murderer Superman has crossed a line
that he cannot come back from that he'll
never be able to come back from not only
that this is going to set Superman on a
collision course that will basically
change everything that's what Tom Taylor
is saying now this changes everything it
turns everything upside down but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end if you guys
enjoyed this make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like I love Injustice right
now by the way I think it's one of the
best stories out there in DC Comics and
yeah I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace